this is Belleville in Southeast
Liverpool and this video was shared with
Sky News by a community who claimed
they're being terrorized by armed
teenagers and police are struggling to
maintain control - of this group have
hammers another a knife sharpener they
were looking for a boy due to testify at
the murder trial of Daniel G Jameson
seen here in the red head guard a keen
boxer but in a fight last July
Daniel was stabbed and killed he was 16
years old just yards from their home his
mother managed to reach him before he
died under the bridge where it happened
where - found Daniel but still recalls
the moment every night the color in his
face drained all his master's wife and I
hold held sound and it was felt a new
color cold and clammy he said to me mom
we just want to go to sleep I said don't
go to sleep please don't go to sleep in
March 17 year-old Owen cousins was
cleared of Daniels murder but sentenced
to 11 years for manslaughter but Mandy
feels the conviction of her son's killer
has done little to calm tension in this
community
she even felt targeted on the day of
Daniels funeral as we left and the cars
pulled away a few of them at the top of
the road waving like this big smile on
the faces going and next thing we had
motorbikes and then we have threatening
all of Diamond stones up at the funeral
saying you're next you're next and then
when I came out I got this they're going
to me you're getting it next as well did
Daniel carry a knife Daniel got caught
with a knife in September 2017 and I
don't condone that Daniel felt that
scared that he couldn't go anyway
without fear of being jumped or stabbed
at all the time you've got to give kids
things to do so they're all killing each
other knife crime has hit a record high
across the country here Merseyside has
seen the second highest rise up 49
percent in the last year falling police
numbers might be partly to blame as well
as gang disputes and teenagers wanting
to
feel protected Merseyside police say
they're still working to understand the
rise and how to tackle it would you say
this is the biggest challenge on your
hands at the moment
it's certainly one of the biggest things
I've seen in my 20 year Police Service
what do you do about it that's that's
the question I think what we need to
remember is there's not one answer
there's not one body or one organization
that can stop the issues around life
crime this has got to be a joint effort
by everyone involved that includes the
public potentially more than anyone else
you know we need the public to tell us
who were carrying knives but more
officers are only part of what's needed
police here say they need to get the
message across to young people they're
more at risk carrying a knife Liverpool
City Council say they've tried to
protect frontline youth work but 66
percent of their central government
funding has been cut since 2010 and the
judge in this case said even after the
death of a teenager no lessons were
learned by this group who arrived tooled
up as he said in the hunt for another
lad
teenagers fighting stabbing dying is not
exclusive to this area and there is no
single answer but this video gives an
ugly insight into the problems
politicians and police are trying to
solve sally Lockwood Sky News Liverpool